now i would like to invite our next
speaker professor palu radhana professor
dethana is currently professor at
university of hyderabad and director at
aspire and executive president at fawah
hyderabad
he has been working for the past 30
years in the area of inflammation and
cancer
he his paper on vehicle trying synthesis
along with professor easy corey who is a
novel lawyer
and the discovery of a new pathway for
the conversion of leukotriene c4 to
legal drain f
4 are the significant contributions
he is involved in setting up of tbi and
yo nest incubation center and founder
member of the federation of asian
biotech association that is power
as well as participating in promoting in
innovations and into
enterpriseship activities in the campus
professor radhana will be talking about
industry driven education in health care
uh health care in india so over to you
professor
thank you
dr
let me first thank
for inviting me
to this
special workshop
or symposium
so
dr mohit has asked me to talk on higher
educational institutions in india
let me first share
my presentation
thank you sir it's a pleasure to have
you
uh
are you able to see my screen
uh yes sir but not in the presentation
are you able to hear properly
uh yes sir
okay
so what i thought was
let me just give a brief background
about the indian
educational system in higher education
and
then what india has contributed
to india
as well as to the global community
and what are the challenges
in
utilizing the talent from higher
educational institutions
by indian industry
and
always we hear the complaint that
the
student community coming out of the
colleges or higher education
institutions
they are
not
having the right skills to be employed
in in the industry
and um
so that is that's the major
complaint and how
how actually we could overcome that kind
of
the deficit that is present in the
indian educational system
what is the way forward so that's how i
have structured
my talk let me just give the global
scenario of
higher educational institutions
so
in general higher education is viewed as
part of the national agenda in
transforming the nation
into knowledge based economy so any kind
of investment that you put in the higher
education is going to give you back
and
contribute to the economy of the country
also
globally if you say there are 30 000
universities are higher educational
institutions
around the world
nearly 600 million students at
universities across all disciplines
four levels of education generally
associate bachelor's master's and
doctoral degrees these are all
different grades that are there
nearly 50 percent of the student
population are going to higher education
in developed countries but not in other
countries if you see the
kind of talent that is being used by
developing countries like u.s and europe
you can see
in usa there are 1 million plus people
students from various countries going
there and then contributing to their
growth
similarly uk 0.5 million china point for
million canada
so the talent wherever it is that is
being exploited by these developed
countries
and
higher educational
institutions indian scenario if you see
there are about 945
universities which includes the state
central private universities deemed to
be universities and among these
54 of the
central universities
and there are
388 private universities 558 medical
colleges
the most important institutions
allied institutions are
indian institute of technologies there
are 23 of them
and they are the major contributors for
innovation and entrepreneurship not only
in india but across the world
and
very recently the government of india
has started
indian institute of scientific education
and research isis
icers are similar to iits
for science
if iits are for engineering isis are for
science and technology
and there are 150 plus standalone
research institutes are there
established by
the
national
funding agencies like council of
scientific industrial research
department of science and technology
department of biotechnology
indian council of medical research like
that
and
3500 plus engineering colleges are they
both
run by the state governments run by the
private universities
and
there are
3400 polytechnics
and 200
architectural
colleges
so you can see the structure either
engineering or medical or
these are the professional
kind of
courses that are being run
and on the other side the conventional
all universities are there with all
multi-disciplinary
structure
and so this
the number of students that are enrolled
into all these educational institutions
it is really
a
large number and in that way india can
boast that we are
generating large
manpower
not only for india but
to the global community
so india is the second largest source of
internationally mobile students around
the world so our students will go to
undergraduate courses or postgraduate
courses or to the higher
postdoctoral programs to various other
countries
nearly three hundred thousand indian
students
in universities and colleges abroad
every year
so that is the kind of formula not only
they are from getting trained in the
educational
system that is there in the country but
they are also going out and then
studying
contributions of
if you see the contributions of higher
educational institutions
sorry
in 2019
42.6 percent of the workforce in india
was employed in agriculture
while the other half was almost evenly
distributed among the two other sectors
industry and services so most of the
of course the kind of workforce
what we are talking in agriculture is
may not be educated but the other kind
of workforce but
the
the
the talent that is coming out of
higher educational institutions are
going into either service sector or
industry sector
india has seen a rapid expansion in the
higher educational sector since 2001
but the number employed in the industry
is very low
the top eight sectors suffering
employment
or
the consumer electronics manufacturing
commercial real estate
food industry tourism textile mining
banking sector automobile
these are the top that means the pharma
biotech and other things come much later
and
at what level they are employed
undergraduate
is around eight percent of the total
employment
so the polytechnic courses i itis
three percent
polytechnic three percent
postgraduate or equivalent kind of
degrees 13 percent
management equivalent to
courses 17 percent
the graduates with the
either
graduates in arts or commerce or science
17 percent engineer is 31
so most of
the employments are the for the
engineers which is followed by the
management equivalent or other kind of
things
so
so that is the scenario
status of industry employment in india
if you see
as i was mentioning earlier 41 percent
uh
employed in the agriculture i.t and
service sector 22 percent
former twelve percent
and
manufacturing fifteen percent
others are
around
the five fast growing
industries are health care industry food
industry digital industry infrastructure
industry
so these are all the various sectors
what india has contributed to higher
the higher educational institutions have
contributed to the global if you see our
talent is employed everywhere india's
highly qualified human services in
abroad are highly varied
and have entered almost all fields of
academy especially iet and health care
sectors
if you see
that 21 of
indian origin star executives are
heading the global companies
that means
this the
the
products coming up out of higher
educational institutions
it is not good to say that they are not
well trained
but these are the people who are heading
the global institutions
you have examples which were given
ajay paul singh
and santanu
and
so a number of
people
are
heading not only just being employed
in the global companies but also at very
key positions also
so that means the indian educational
system has contributed a lot
to the growth of the global
industry
our global economy
but why indian industry is not able to
tap that kind of talent
why they are
allowing them to go and sell in others
if let us see the scenario
how it is in india
for my industry
it is very innovative in reverse
engineering in fact they are the
leaders in generics
and
supplying
the medicines at much cheaper prices
around the world
and in fact they have contributed a lot
to the healthcare industry around the
world
specifically in developing countries
which cannot afford the medicine
it is the indian industry which has come
forward and then supplied at much
cheaper prices
for
diseases like
hiv
and many other
disorders
so but
they are mostly concentrated on generic
when the new ipr regime came we thought
probably our pharma industry will enter
into innovation
but that didn't happen because of the
generic opportunity and now they all the
pharma industries
they're also global leaders but they are
thriving on the genetic opportunity
new drug discovery is still a challenge
in the former industry let us see
biotech industry
biotech industry
so
initially
it all started with the first hip
recombinant
hepatitis b vaccine that was shrink walk
developed by santa by attack
because of the contributions of
two main persons in dr gunduka from
santa barbara tech
and the manager
uh managed by dr verb sadradi an
establishment of many other biotech
industries
and today
the kovid vaccines are being developed
and distributed around the world
so the industry again has for biotech
industry has
also come up similar to pharma industry
but again
uh biosimilars not innovative to
production
very recently you know indian companies
also have just to come up with
the noaa to
vaccine for the kovite 19
by bharath biotic and gyrus cadilla also
has come up
for the first time dna vaccine
so the bio biosimilars have given the
opportunity for the biotech industry
and biopharmaceutical segment accounted
for the largest share of the biotech
industry with 64 of the total revenues
and
the they are also following the by
generic group as i said by similars and
vaccines and biosimilars contribute to
the largest component
and in the entire biotech in the stream
there are not many
innovative products
which were
introduced
so what is the next phase for the parma
and biopharma industry
discovery root is the
only way to to become the global leaders
and then come up with blockbuster
products
challenges it is really highly risky
time consuming require huge investments
but
the pharma and biotech industry in the
country
have that kind of capabilities to
introduce the products but they are not
coming forward what is the way forward
new models have to be adopted
so any kind of innovations around the
world have come from academic
institutions
it is the academic institutions which
have come up with the innovations
which the global
industries
have taken up exploited and then taken
to the later development so that is the
model which india also has to adopt
academy in the forefront and industry at
later stages of development so that high
risk is mitigated in the academic
institutions which are supported by the
government
whereas
the later development could be taken by
the industry
and to promote academy industry
interactions
specifically if you want to import the
right skills required
for the
manpower for the industry
there should be continued dialogue
between industry and academy
and that can happen with
the push from academic institutions
for
collaboration
with the industry and the pull
from whatever the ideas innovations
coming out of the academic institutions
have to be
exploited by the industry so these
models may be thought of from push from
the owners of ip that is from academic
institutions and the pull from foreign
biotech industries
and these models have to be
adopted which will help
for the growth of the industry
so adaption of
innovation
is the success that is this
that that's the
innovation is the game changer in the
global companies companies founded on
scientific discoveries or meaningful
engineering innovation
or the leaders
if indian industry has to become the
global leaders it is the only mantra is
to
focus on innovations that means
engage with the academic institutions
and then promote the innovation of
discoveries in the academic
institutions
and
so if you see
the the various areas where
see the field is rapidly changing unless
you adopt to the new technologies that
are coming up are emerging
you will not be able to survive and then
come up with innovative products
so
so that's where the no you need to be in
a position to
adopt the technologies like artificial
intel intelligence machine learning data
mining
so a number of such kind of innovation
technologies
are
tools that are emerging
they need to be
adopted and
that is possible only when you have
continued interaction with the industry
the uni industry has to be
continuously engaged with the academic
institutions and the academic
institutions also should have
continuation what are the kind of skill
set that is required in the industry and
how to introduce them into the
curriculum these are the things
and
the expanding pool of professionals in
india is set to become one of the
largest talent pool in the world by
2027.
so
enable each and every sector
so
there will be a lot of talent that will
be available
and that talent
the right skills that are required
have to be imported into the
curriculum of the educational
institutions
and
so
if you see the forecast five things to
know about india by 2013 it will be
second largest economy
even
ahead of yes that is the kind of
projections more than one billion
internet users 77 percent of the
population under the age of 44 80
percent of the population is middle
class
and 5.7 trillion
consumer spending so that kind of market
you will not get in any other country so
that is why
it is going to be
india
is going to be the global focus in the
years to come industries need to exploit
the talent from these higher educational
institutions and involve them in
innovative discoveries
so initial reskilling
some background noise is coming
yes uh professor paolo ridhana you need
to understand
yeah
yeah yeah
so
so far india has been
recognized as a manufacturing hub
so it is a global manufacturing center
for either vaccines or by for the former
products but
the question is will they graduate
when they are going to graduate
so
there is enormous scope for
indian industries
to come up with innovative products
so
the advantages
for india is sixth largest consumer
market in the world 31 percent of urban
population 49 workforce participation
attracted more than 49 billion
investments in 2009 so the government is
also providing all kind of incentives
for the industry to come up
but
the industry has to
focus on innovation and innovate to
project products and then only they will
be global leaders
in every sector that they are taking
so
the pharma and biopharma sectors
specifically supplying the products
around the world but the time to focus
on innovation it has come up
so
what is the way forward here deep in
academy industry relations adoption of
immersion technology
that is whatever the new tools that are
coming up aaml another iot
all have to be adopted
so that you're up to date
then only you will be in the race
otherwise you will be left out
innovation and entrepreneurship track
introducing no curriculum track aimed at
to equip future refugee
scientists at higher education
institutions with business
fundamentals and familiarity with the
entrepreneurship
so academic institutions should also
start
such kind of innovation and
entrepreneurship activities
and more importantly skill development
clusters
have to be developed organizing
organizations bringing together academy
and industry
an open innovation platform to provide
skills and training to freshers and
reskilling experienced employees so that
is the one which
will promote innovative industry
the thing
and
so india has come up with the
new educational policy
and it emphasizes them
on holistic multi-disciplinary education
for future nations
stakeholders
so keeping in mind of the skill set that
is coming out of the
indian educational institutions the new
educational policy
is
has come up with a lot of um
changes
revamping the entire system
internationalization of higher education
that is
very soon in the academic institutions
there will be not only students but even
the faculty will be recruited wherever
the best talent that is
digitalization of the
is another important thing that is
now today in every discipline every
segment of the industry also
that data science is the one which is
playing an important role so you need to
you you need to empower the students
with the digital
technologies digital infrastructure
digital content
and capacity building of institutes in
technology
for education
a laid accreditation system also has
been going to be introduced so that
the the universities and institutions
can could be ranked basing on the type
of skills that they are importing
and also the kind of
the contributions that they have made to
the industry or to the academy
not only
to
training the students but even the
teaching faculty also need to be
empowered with
reskilling and upskilling
of the professionals that is also
business
so it is all aimed at
making india self-reliant
and making india to boost the economy
and
to meet sustainable goals of india
so that's the way
so
industry driven education system must be
is the focus establishing links with
industrial academy is crucial higher
education institution to import the
right skill set required in the industry
and promoting innovation and
entrepreneurship ecosystem in the
campuses
push from the academic institutions and
pull from the industries
so this is
with reference to
yeah so in summary
india with the largest world's largest
population of 500 million
in the age of 5 24
years and the largest network of higher
educational institutions in the world
played an important role in every sector
not only in india but even
around the world
however there is still lot of potential
for further development
provided the right skills are imported
by the educational institutions
and this requires continued interaction
of the educational institutions
with the industries
to understand the dynamic skill set
required
with changing times
and industries
should come up with reskill of the
professionals and potential employees
in collaboration with the academic
institution
those skill at the academic institutions
and the race skill at the
industries level both are required to
make them employable which is being
adapted by
the
global industries so the push from
academic institutions and the pull from
the industries are required to generate
industry manpower in every industrial
segment
including the health care so that is
what i thought but in this connection i
also wanted to
introduce
the federation of asian biotech
associations which we started in 2004 to
provide the platform for the academy
industry
and government to come together
so this is a non-profit organization
providing such kind of
platform for the academy industry to
come together and interact
and we also has a
we are making sure that
to promote innovation through innovation
awards for the young scientists
and young minds at the school level
itself
and we are in the process of
having a global innovation clusters made
and
hyderabad innovation cluster mate is
also being planned
so there
and very recently we have started baba
academy and this academy is mainly to
train the students
in
helping the students in their career
building and also skill development
activities
so it is not only the responsibility of
the academic institutions and the
industries but organizations like fiber
have been to weaken doing
so we are identifying what are the right
skills required in the industry and then
incorporating them into our workshops
and then
importing to the student community and
in this connection we also have
collaborated with pine bio in this
effort
let me also tell you briefly
university of hyderabad one among the
top five universities in the country
with the 12 schools of study
in this
the chemistry physics life sciences are
the
leading
science and technology schools
school of life sciences
is one of the largest
life science school in the
country with almost 75 faculty members
in one roof
and received the
best university award and
awarded rpa great very recently it was
recognized as institute of eminence
under which there are special grants
which were given
so with that i stop and i'll be happy to
take any questions
thank you
uh thank you professor adana for the
insights
so we
have a few questions and also some
reviews already so we really appreciate
uh your presentation today and so much
information that we got to know for the
first time so i was pretty much engaged
throughout this presentation
learning so many new things about the
ongoing effort and especially what are
the changes that uh the
government and the industry is going
through to accommodate the
transformation
so
um to summarize this entire two sessions
before i maybe
go to some of the questions that have
been asked so i just wanted to summarize
for everyone that um
it was great to first listen to dr gps
raghuwa where we learned about the
application of bioinformatics and what
the importance of data is now uh
by professor sridhana's talk we got to
know about the opportunity so the
opportunity also involves
data science education and biotechnology
and healthcare in this healthcare
industry so one of the aspect that we
kind of wanted to discuss is that uh
one thing that was coming out of this
entire uh presentation and the way we
have been presenting ourselves as uh
the future of bioinformatics in india
is that how do we
do it in here in india
by working with
government uh by by working with
industry by connecting to industry and
being able to do and generate and have
these soft skills and skill sets that
are the future
so uh with that uh i would wanted to ask
some of the questions that are there put
together uh so one of the question that
came in in the chat
is uh
by sri prashad joshi so shri prasha
joshi is saying dr ridhana thanks for
the amazing talk i sincerely feel that
he i from
india uh
except iit and icer plus some elite
institute the academy is not providing
enough experience from the practical
side to the graduating student
so i feel like it is a must to get a
large number of pass outs both with a
degree as well as profound knowledge in
at least their research interest i would
like to know that what do you think
about this
thanks again
yeah i think this is the scenario
uh
in most of
most parts part of parts of the country
the students
see
the skill set is a dynamic one it is
ever changing
but at the same pace
the
so infrastructural facilities or
the in terms of the
faculty strength
or
faculty expertise is not changing
that is where we need to have
continued engagement with the industry
every institution has to engage with the
industry but that is not happening
and
but despite that
our
uh our work for our student
you know the products coming out of the
academic institutions
are able to
gain knowledge from
the
so
maybe they need some kind of bridge
courses and those kind of bridge courses
are the ones which are they
which are being offered outside either
u.s or europe
somebody does the msc here and then go
for phd
or somebody has done even phd also and
then go to
u.s or europe or
some other countries and then work for a
couple of years learn those kind of
skill set and then they are the ones
which are leading which are
being employed by the industry either
either they come back to india and join
the industries or they are the working
then
there itself
but there are opportunities if they are
not available
at
your colleges such as universities but
if you go around and then tap the
resources see today
there are so many central universities
isis
iits
the students who could not
get the proper skill set or hands-on
training they can go for internships
they can write to the faculty at
universities central universities
or
there are national laboratories which i
said
bst or the csr or dbt labs are there you
could always write and then go
do internships that's where you learn
some of the skill set
if one has that kind of willingness to
go out and then learn
there are enough opportunities in the
country
and it is not good always complaining
that no they are not being provided and
to the population that we have it is
impossible to provide such kind of you
cannot have iit sizes or central
universities in each
and every corner
but those who are not having
they should tap the other resources that
are available in the country
so that's my advice to the students
okay so thank you thank you for uh
answering that question so we also have
dr hartreet as a panelist so if she has
a question
yes
um thank you doctor
thank you dr ritana for such a wonderful
talk so i have a question like we all
want
uh industrial oriented research in india
but i have one question whether
industries are sponsoring doctoral
degree for the phd student so one of the
research fellowship that i am familiar
with they are actually industrial parts
partners are also involved that is pm uh
fellowship prime minister fellowship so
apart from that uh do you have some idea
like from pure or what are the
industries that sponsoring phd for uh
indian students so that they actually
develop such kind of skills at their uh
doctoral level
yeah thank you
yeah i think pm
pm prime minister's
doctoral fellowship is really a very
good one where industries are involved
but
it all depends upon the educational
institutions for example at university
of hyderabad
we collaborated with santa bartek
shantha baiter gave the fellowships for
phd program
and the scientists at santa barbara tech
could also work for phd in
collaboration with the faculty
at the university of hyderabad dr
reddy's laboratories also the scientists
from there could
so i was a co-guide for
the students from dr radisson so
the those kind of opportunities are
there but it all depends upon how
exactly the academic institutions are
exploiting it is not just
somebody no industry will come and give
you the fellowship
but
it all depends upon how one interacts
and then gets them
so another question that i have as you i
mean indicated dr reddy and other labs
are offering uh sponsorship
so whether the students who are
acquiring that degree are going to
acquire those degrees whether they also
need to clear some like exams like csiro
csr research fellowship or utc research
fellowship
kind of exam
before applying for those kind of
fellowships
it's not uh
see university is the one which
decides the eligible criteria for phd
either the entrance examination or the
csir
exam it varies from one university to
another university
no
if they have a policy that they will
admit through the entrance exam
conducted by them
then you have to pass that exam
otherwise if csr fellowship
see for example iasc will not just
rely on csir or icm or dbt fellowships
and
awards that they get but they internally
conduct
their own exam and then take so the
policy varies
okay so another question like how many
fellowships they offer in any in one
year for example we know that uh like
100 to 200 students are
sponsored by csir for their doctoral
degree and nearly uh two to three
hundred or something like that are
sponsored by udc for their doctor nikki
so how many i mean in terms of a number
for every year these companies sponsor
the phd student
the number is not
number number is not something that
you need to negotiate
is is not a
uniform thing
see for example santa bartek gave the
fellowships to all the msc students
so when we were about 12 to 12 around 15
to 20 they were all given the fellowship
and then
two or three
it depends upon them
industry
is not a fixed which they announce and
then
give
okay thank you thank you dr